[Music]
sorry you cried as Becca was sending you
home as she was telling you goodbye yeah
then you cried in the car no actually I
didn't cry when she sent me home I was
just trying to process everything it was
a shock to me I did not think I was
gonna go home I thought I was good to go
I did everything that I wanted to do up
to that point when she sent me home my
wall kind of Miele came back up and in
my exit interview I was just very very
upset trying to process everything and
then once I got out of the car that's
kind of when all the tears flow I mean
you told them pull over the car yeah I
was ready to get out because because I
wanted to have it even though I know I
don't have any personal time I wanted to
get out of the car and just kind of let
everything how it had been a long
journey a lot of emotions a lot of
intensity a lot of you know effort and
it kind of came to an end abruptly and I
just needed to let it up so why do you
say pull over the cars because there are
still producers in the car with you and
you needed a total I just I mean I was
in a confined space I wanted some air I
just wanted to kind of be with myself
for a second and just let it all out so
how long is that car ride how long are
you in tears of I meant to be honest
that car ride felt like forever I think
that's part of the reason I just wanted
to get out but I mean my mind was all
over the place at that time I didn't
really know well I got sent home I was
kind of questioning myself a lot I just
I don't know I just really just kind of
wanted to run away screaming a little
bit but you know I try to compose myself
and you know I wasn't really upset at
Beca I just upset the situation what was
it like to watch it that last night um
to be honest every time I watched myself
I'm very proud um I left everything out
there that I you know I wanted to do I
told her exactly I felt when I felt it
and she just decided that I wasn't going
for it and I can't not that do you feel
like you want more answers on that I
mean mental all will happen how are you
feeling to be honest I don't really I
kind of I don't really want to live in
the past anymore watching that it's all
this back I've been living in the past
for a while I told her that night as
long as she's happy I'm happy
I don't really need any more answers she
kind of showed me how she felt and
that's fine and as long as she's happy
with one of my best friends whoever they
may be I'm good
about a year ago and some change I don't
really know exactly but I felt very very
alone in this world and just seeing all
you guys reach out to me and show me
love and respect I really really
appreciate it
getting a little motional seriously
really really appreciate it thank you
guys all of you seriously I love hearing
that yeah did the show help you get out
of that place
absolutely Becca mainly helped me get
out of that place and all the guys and
all the crew and producers helped me as
well there's a huge family can you talk
about what it was that had kind of
gotten you into that moment what moment
when you said you felt very long oh I
just you know I was coming off a hard
breakup and I just didn't really feel
wanted by anyone I kind of had a couple
you know grows off excuse me women I was
speaking to and it just didn't work out
and I just started questioning myself is
this tough time wills for bachelor was
trending after your exit last night on
Twitter yes how does that make you feel
we know you went to Paradise yes yeah
man that's the last night uh-huh yeah
what happens in Paradise you gotta find
out you're gonna find out so stay tuned
watch that can you tell us are you
single right now I cannot you can't tell
us I'm shocked it and expect that answer
but bachelor well I guess we'll have to
see what happens in Paradise but would
you be the bachelor I'm open to any and
every opportunity I'm not gonna say no
you know if someone comes and talks to
me that's a discussion to be had and I'm
all for it
I mean it would be amazing because
there's been so much love for you and of
course we still have not had an
african-american bachelor so do you feel
like that's true I mean is I feel like
it's a bit of a double-edged sword I
mean being on The Bachelorette I wanted
to make my family and my friends and
everyone you know proud of me so I feel
like being the first african-american
bachelor would be a tall task but I feel
like it's something I can handle I've
everything I've been through in my life
I've handled so far and I think I could
handle that
[Music]